city of Southern California for the past
four years or so prior to that it's in
its 21st year it was held on the campus
of UCLA our full schedule available at
book tv.org and now joining us on our
call-in set here at LA is author and
actor Taye Diggs his most recent book is
called mixed me mr. Diggs what inspired
mixed me ah my son walked in the clan yo
did he is a product of a mixed
relationship me being african-american
and his mother being a Russian Jewish
white woman has he had issues being that
he has not we are luckily we have them
enrolled in a school where you know
there are more kids that look like him
then then than the other but I still
felt it was important for me to tell
this story just because you know there
are so many people out there regardless
of ethnicity that feel different and I
feel like kids these days especially in
light of all of the bullying and would
not need to know that it's okay to have
a healthy self-esteem it's okay to to
love and appreciate oneself and that's
that's what this book is about it's the
second in a series the first one was
called shot with me about my own
experiences and and the second one is a
second one it makes me and the character
is kind of loosely based on on myself
about 9 million people according to the
US Census Bureau are identifying as
being from a mixed keraton what are some
of the issues that mixed kids face oh my
goodness I mean it goes on and on and on
arm
well for starters identification you
know what what and who they are and who
to whom that they identify I got into uh
there was a lot of hubbub recently when
I was doing pressed for this book I was
trying to explain to an interviewer that
I wanted Walker to be proud of both
and his father when it when it came to
race and a lot of the african-americans
kind of contingently interpreted
interpreted that as me saying I didn't
want my son to be called black um not
only way they can get pretty pretty
hairy because you know there's a
difference I think between ethnicity and
identity you know in America if you have
you know a few drops of black blood in
you supposedly you are supposed to
identify with being blackness is what
what is supposed to do so you know a lot
of african-american kind of took offense
to that
when when I was just saying you know I
want my going to be proud of both both
sides you know so that's an issue um
Harmons growing up some of the new kids
were forced to pick you know what kind
of friends you know if you were mixed
and you hung out with the white kid then
you weren't black enough or vice-versa
their issues with hair you know there
are issues with people mistaking you for
something that you're not and I don't
know how many times friends of mine have
been chilling out and and and somebody
walked up to them in just like the kicks
Spanish to them
so you know it's it's it's it's it's an
issue and and now that I'm getting older
and
and doing you know the press for this
book I'm hearing all these stories of
these young people who had you know a
certain period of their childhoods taken
from them because they weren't allowed
to identify with their white mother or
their Latin father because uh you know
they would get harassed at school um and
some of these stories are really they're
really sad you know it's too bad you
know how we are we all I mean I
understand it but you know we as human
beings we feel the need to categorize
and you know a label just for our own
edification not out of fear going to
mean instead of just accepting people
for whom they are okay Dick's will be
with us for the next 20 minutes or so if
you'd like to call in we're talking
about his book mix me his first book was
chocolate me and we're talking about
generally the issue of race in America
particularly from his perspective 2:02
area code seven four eight eighty two
hundred if you live in the eastern
central time zone seven four eight eight
two zero one for those of you in the
mountain and Pacific time zones now if
you want to send a text message not a
phone call but a text message to zero to
seven one seven nine six eight four
we've also got a couple of ways that you
can contact us by social media Twitter
and Facebook we'll put those addresses
up as we go along as well Taye Diggs you
mentioned that there was a bit of a
kerfuffle when you were doing press for
this book but I'm going to I'm going to
quote you here and let you talk about
this and we're talking about President
Obama here and this is you speaking
everybody refers to him is the first
black president I'm not saying it's
wrong I'm just saying that it's
interesting it would be great if it
didn't matter and that people could call
him
yeah so do you consider him to be the
first black president I do I do
but that's only because I'm playing by
the rules that that have already been
set here what I'm saying I always I
always tell my friends I bet you you
know I would bet you that growing up
there were black folks that did not
accept him or black folks that said he
talked white and you know after you
reach a certain level a lot of times
these same black folks turn that around
and say okay well now that you've
established yourself now we can accept
you but I mean you know we we as a race
you know from and because of slavery
we've been put through so much that when
it comes down identity it's it's
confusing it's really confusing I can
understand how you know we as like
people want to find as many from our
tribes as possible
I get that but at some point that's
going to have to it's going to have to
end because where do you draw the line
where are you going to draw the line you
know there are some black people that
that are lighter than you and I'm saying
and and they've been treated a certain
way their entire lives and it's just
it's not fair you know I forget at some
point we're going to have to we're going
to have to move on
do you think that because of your
notoriety as an actor that perhaps your
son has an easier time of it
I would probably say yes only in that we
have a little bit we have a little bit
of money so we can afford to send them
to certain schools where you know
diversity is is paramount um I don't
know what his experience would be where
he to go to a public school um I don't
know
but uh you know I know and this is what
I do know regardless of who I am he's
gonna he's going to you know you know
he's going to come across some problems
I mean he's going to come across some
kids whether it's college or high school
or Wall Street that are going to ask him
you know with whom he identified I
remember a while back
Tiger Woods not saying that that he was
black and everybody getting so upset
um for me it just made sense you know
but people you know when it comes to
ethnicity and race and people people
take it very very seriously but good
reason I'm sorry
you know go ahead with good reason but
you know we do we got we got it we got
it
we got to try to move on 2016 mm-hmm
what do you think about the conversation
the conditions of race in this country
I'm in checking out it it's getting
better it's nowhere near you know I'll
try to stay positive it's getting better
it's getting better we've got a ways to
go but uh but it's getting better
and I'm very I'm very hopeful I'm trying
to
to come from a place of understanding
and and love you know people can get
very angry and aggressive and at times
the chickens that can become easy to
kind of fall into a defensive mode but
I'm trying you know I'm trying to
understand and be empathetic and
hopefully uh you know if we all can kind
of you know walk walked in community
with the fact with that vibe you know
things would get better
also I'd like to write a children's book
oh man what's the number one rule for
writing a children I don't know man I'm
just for you
I'm just for me it's got to be fun you
know I I'm excited that I found my own
kind of rhyming rhythm poetry and I've
been very fortunate to work with one of
my very best friends I call them my
cousin give you Shane Evans he's the
illustrator and and being able to work
with one of your best friend is awesome
you know um being able to see him you
know put art suited to the words that
I've come up with is a you know it's
like opening presents on Christmas
morning
I don't know let's take some calls Taye
Diggs you've seen them in rent you've
seen him in wicked you've seen him in
how Stella got her groove back have you
seen him in private practice and a good
wife as well so long ago hi there
first call up for him is Dorothy in
Haiti Missouri Dorothy you're on book TV
good morning good morning good morning
hello Dorothy Dorothy Lois may please go
ahead with your question or comment yes
um jeito
my granddaughter she's mixed and she is
absolutely beautiful and she's in the
8th grade we kind of have a difference
for a problem here in our school with
her she has problems with the black kids
in school we had to take her out of
school in homeschooler
white kids have expected her but the
black kids are the ones that are
bullying her and giving her trouble and
[Music]
you know with yeah a yes our town we
have a lot of prejudice in our town we
have a small rural town and you know
it's there but that's what has surprised
us so you have any explanation for that
Phoenix whoo
I mean there are tons of people out
there that can can relate and I'm sorry
that your family has to go through that
but it's as I as I said earlier you know
African decide should say you know most
ethnicities you know better than kind of
disenfranchise would that work have
issues and that is one of the the issues
that we as has a raised carry you know
wanting to include or not include people
for certain reasons based on on how they
look or how they speak or or how they
dress and and and how that kind of plays
into rape I understand it but once again
you know it's it's hurtful it's harmful
and it can be it can be first of all it
can be harmful and and it's something we
need to work on another call from
Missouri this is Dan in Camden to
Missouri go ahead Dan we're listening
yes mr. dig up I had a relationship with
a number of blacks either friends or or
working and my question is how do you
feel about the psychological effects of
blacks in America who don't absque ribe
to being african
whoo tell you what Taye Diggs what did
you hear from that call what did you
hear
what did I of American American this
gentleman wants to know where I stand on
I guess and correct me if I'm wrong
African Americans that don't identify
with being African that's that's an
interesting question once again you know
we're making up these rules as we go
along and the difficulty with that is
that there's no real right or wrong
because we're making it up so African
American next up that's a made-up word
you know I've never been to Africa I
don't know for a fact if my lineage is
from Africa but that's something that's
that's that's a term that we came up
with I think for ease you know um so
it's hard to speak on on something like
that when you know there is no cemented
answer you know I think the term comes
from a time when black people needed to
feel like a group they needed to feel we
needed to feel unified um
strong powerful
so you know once again I get it but you
know when you're when you're making
things up as you go along you start to
run into some some bumps in the road and
you get people out there that that want
a exact answer and when it comes to race
and ethnicity and Prejudice there are
there are no there are no exact answer
you know those last two calls are both
from Missouri are 92 calls are from
California folk' outlined area do you
think that the problems are the issues
faced by those two in Missouri are going
to be the same issues faced out here in
Southern California
sure sure it's all over its it from a
permeate to the world it's all over you
know that that's one thing you can
always count on unfortunately you can
always count on people drawing lines and
wanting to separate unfortunately I
think I feel on I feel like it's part of
our nature you know the name let miss
someone
and then making a judgement so that you
can identify them and better understand
them you know and I think through
through the years we've we've tried to
do that in many different ways and race
race has been one of them you know
that's why you get into these issues
with you know a black and I remember
yeah I remember I remember in college I
was in an African American Studies class
and as we were talking about stereotypes
there was a black a young black man
skateboarding
out the window you know outside the
window and about four or five scared you
know pointed that pointed point him out
and said how how he would get the white
sport wife we doing that white sport
riding skateboard you know
as opposed to what like playing
basketball or you know and then you have
on this on the converse side people
getting upset when folks assume that you
are great at basketball because in black
you know um it's it's muddy messy and
you know it's uh it's complicated
lilia right here in Los Angeles all
right you're on with authors a digs
please go ahead thank you sure I've
never really read any of your books but
okay for the past 22 years I have been
going to a very deep Indian Reservation
in South Dakota and I'm a hooker one of
the most amazing things that I heard
from legitimate genuine medicine man was
this but he said do you know that if you
are an FBI what and a full-blooded
Indian you're an FBI they would not
trust you to get any credit then if you
are a mixed Indian lesson what is that I
don't know they just think that we
full-blooded Indians cannot be trusted
while the mixed Indians can be trusted
and I died recently this old man I
really loved him
and I remember that when I was listening
to us with a date just a common all
right maybe thank you for that any
response for her today
wow that's uh you know it's all of these
these questions you know the answers of
the comments of you know they all come
from a similar place which is it's too
bad and you know we are the people
[Music]
well in a lot of cases we are ruled by
fear
a similar situation is with
african-americans you know a lot of
mixed-race
folks are considered to have good hair
you know when I was growing up the
light-skinned African Americans were
always considered better looking you
know so it's uh it's something that that
we are struggling with and whereas I
continue to say I can understand where
it comes from but at the end of the day
I think it is more polarizing than that
there's more of a spirit of that as
opposed to bringing bringing people
together and you grew up in Newark New
Jersey I grew up in Rochester New York
yeah born born in Newark raised in
Rochester New York Terrence is in
Pasadena right here in the Southern
California area
I'm Terrence go ahead with your question
or comment hello thank you for taking my
call
once I guess I already don't ask mr.
Diggs with regards to understand your
you exclusively big white women and I
guess my question would be have you
delved into the psychology around that
and the other question I have is with
regards to the societal ills that black
Americans face in this country can we
really afford to be taking on the
struggles that mixed-race kids have I
mean how do we how do we embrace
something else on top Harris or near
african-american yes I am thank you sir
Taye Diggs
uh first off I don't date exclusively
white women that's wrong so there's that
and secondly a problem is a problem and
problems need to be dealt with
as my son I love my son if he has a and
Eirik and he cuts his knee on the side
on the sidewalk I don't let the cut on
his knee bleed because I'm taking care
of the lyric I helped him with his
earache and then I helped him with his
cut problems need to be solved and and
it's just that simple I kind of find it
difficult to believe or understand how
how being a member of the earth
you would you would say certain problems
need to be taken care of and you know
prioritizing certain problems as opposed
to others you know what about the
homeless what about education like are
we just supposed to ignore all of those
problems and just deal with with the
problems that you know african-american
side know we have problems it sucks and
we need to deal with them
have you heard those comments before
such as what's not good fun to say not
this one no not this one a couple of
texts that we've received I'd like to
congratulate Taye Diggs for saying and
writing what a lot of people are simply
afraid to speak about keep up the good
work bang come from area code eight five
nine by the way could you send a text
you could include your first name and
city that would be great and this one as
well a shout out to takes for the movie
the would a great movie about friendship
and growing of age and here is one from
Carl in Detroit what race do you
consider your son black white mix and
why race what I will answer that if this
person can define race via text so okay
there we go
haha you define it Bria in Landover
Maryland in the Washington DC area Bria
go ahead you're on with cadence hi Tay I
want to congratulate you on your project
hi come on you know that's all we're all
God's children first of all and first of
all good point yeah let's start there
and when he allows that egg to meet that
verb and that life created we are all
here - were all meant to be here - Nick
and I must conclude by saying I have 51
years old I am african-american not that
I've ever set foot in Africa but I know
that my roots that my origin comes from
what my people were forced here from
that region so that's how I identified
myself as an African America but I am
simply one I've never been married I
have no children I just think it's sad
that we put our own desires to love like
I'm glad you found someone you could
love and that you could share that
portion of your life with that created
the life
but is that for people who choose
interracial relationships in that
consider the legacy they are passing on
to their children in the world of racism
and bigotry you know I just hope that if
I find someone I'm up to old how to
smile but if I do I want to adopt those
that are already here elite love and
good to be nurtured and cannot pass all
of us you know related to my selfishness
really like I am nine years old right
Bria you're 51 years old you say has has
the relationship conversation etc about
race in America changed in your lifetime
I don't think it's changed I think that
it's become more exposed I think you
know back when I was a little girl as we
were you know overt it wasn't so blatant
although certain kind of my grandmother
who are my favorite really fierce giving
woman she's real and she had a very
dark-skinned mother and a European
father so while I'm sure during like my
mother's mother's era she was born in
nineteen just a day was the seventh
would have been her birthday she was
been 102 she died in 94 recipes baby
Brisco alright Bria we're going to have
to leave it there I apologize
Taye Diggs would you hear from Bria
I understand where she's coming from and
I you know I commend her she has the
right to you know today to you know hold
any kind of relationship she chooses um
and and and that's her prerogative for
me I choose to work from the heart and
and as she said accept and appreciate
all of God's children you know if you
pick one one specific type you there's
no way you could pick one specific type
type without excluding others and I
believe and not being inclusive period
is writing addictive is there a third
book oh yes
probably going to be more yes yes yes
I'm very excited about the secret ah
it's a Secret Service oh my goodness
mix me yes is the name of the book
chocolately was the first book the
author Taye Diggs thanks for being on
good to see you my friend all right book
TV's live coverage from the LA Times
Festival of Books continues now